NBC is news is reporting as one in five
American adults wonder how to pay off
their combined 1.6 trillion dollars in
student loan debt Sallie Mae executives
and sales team members wrestled with a
different question between meetings
should they spend their time on their
five day paid trip to the luxury
fairmont resort on walia walia beach in
Maui yep Sallie Mae brought more than
100 of its employees to Hawaii in August
to celebrate a record year of five
billion dollars in student loans made to
three hundred and seventy four thousand
borrowers the company said it didn't pay
for the employees families to attend but
some did tag along Sallie Mae just sent
a hundred folk to the Fairmont which is
a pretty sweet property in Maui guys
this has reached the point that these
scum burgers really don't even
understand how bad their optics are on
this this has reached the point of sheer
stupidity Sallie Mae and navient are
both getting hammered for their lack of
service their mistreatment of borrowers
and they're celebrating another five
billion dollars that you and I as
taxpayers government-insured student
loans were made to another three hundred
and seventy four thousand borrowers and
they're in Maui dancing on Your Grave
and your Congress continues to allow
this to happen it when are we gonna wake
up in this country and realize the idea
of loaning an eight and an
eighteen-year-old
$100,000 unsecured to get a degree in
underwater basket-weaving is a stupid
but idea when are we going to realize
that the student loan
problem is not just a problem it's an
epic plague and Congress caused it and
Congress and only Congress can stop it
it's way past time to stop the federally
insured student loan program if it's so
bad that you left winger dingers out
there think we have to forgive the loans
then how is it anything except
intellectual dishonesty to continue
making the loans while you're talking
about forgiving them that's just not
logical
now politics in Washington has never
been logical and when people are trying
to make a point do you think you can
that you to get your vote and to get you
to do stupid stuff like vote for them
they'll say and do anything but if we're
gonna forgive 1.6 trillion dollars in
student loan debt or even going to have
a discussion about that how is it okay
that these scum burgers are working on
their tan and Maui how is this okay
under what set of rules under what set
of screwed up toxic psychology could you
possibly get to the idea that this is
morally right it's just not and it's out
of control it's got to stop so I was
speaking to a group of highly
influential business guys this morning
and I always get the question in the Q&A
Dave do you ever get invited to
Washington to tell people how to balance
their checkbook they're like yeah I get
invited all the time I quit going
because the only reason they really
wanted me there was so they could say
when next time they did a campaign that
Dave Ramsey came at their request they
were just trying to use my name and my
brand for their political gain they
intended to do nothing and so I quit
wasting my breath instead the best thing
I can figure out to do is to activate
all of you to either fire their butt or
light their offices up until they decide
they're gonna stop making student loans
oh and by the way there's another way
we can put them out of business right
quit taking out student loans tada
I mean even if they kept making them if
you just quit taking them out we could
make it where it isn't so cool for
navient and Sallie Mae to have a
hundreds come burgers working on their
tan at the Fairmont and Maui but
celebrating the fact that another 5
billion dollars has been peddled I could
use other words to 374,000 more
borrowers guys this is ridiculous and
the more we get into this mess the
student loan thing the bigger a problem
we see it is the bigger the predatory
actions of these guys are the stupidity
of the cultural acceptance where it has
just become accepted that you can't be a
student without a student loan Dave
you're a dream killer no baby I'm a
nightmare killer and I'm a nightmare for
people who want to put people into a
nightmare too because I got a big loud
voice and I'm gonna step all over your
butt if you don't quit messing people
over so yes I'm a dream killer if your
idea of a dream is going $235,000 in
debt to get a degree and left-handed
puppetry from from Harvard so you can
say you went to Harvard then I am here
to kill your dream because your dream is
getting ready to become a nightmare in
the 42 year old version of you while
you're still paying that crap back is
gonna hate the 22 year old version of
you and you're going to want to smack
your stupid butt high school guidance
counselor who didn't give guidance and
you're going to strangle your parents
when they didn't stand up to you and say
no you're 18 and you're stupid you're
not doing that I want to kill nightmares
I want to kill nightmares if you want to
call that killing a dream if you if your
dream is to go deeply in debt to get a
degree so you can say you went to a
certain school I am here to kill your
dream because you're gonna find that to
not be a dream when you get out here in
the real world because in the real world
nobody gives a rip where you went to
school they just wonder if you'd learn
something while you were there that's
actually useful
that's all they want to know
did you learn something just getting a
degree is not your ticket just getting a
degree from a famous university is not
your ticket success is not caused by
those things success is caused by hustle
and grind and knowledge in hustle and
grind and some more knowledge and
character and integrity and perseverance
and hustle and grind and some more
knowledge and this is where success
comes from it doesn't come from where
you went to school that's the dumbest
but thing I ever heard in my life
and you've got to quit telling these
lies to each other out there people it's
time to stop this mess hey you guys go
to borrowed future and download the prob
future podcast and listen to those lady
episodes you're gonna get us pissed off
as I am when you're if you listen to
this stuff you'll be going this is
ridiculous
this is absolutely asinine borrowed
future wherever you listen to podcasts
borrowed future calm with its Apple
Google Play whatever Spotify go listen
to this thing there's eight episodes I
think we've downloaded four of them now
and it is absolutely rockin and this
article wasn't even out when we did this
we would have compound on this thing
good gosh